ja und jetzt wollen wir nach hongkong
hongkong schauen schon wieder kommt es
dort zu demonstrationen und die polizei
geht mit voller härte mit wasserwerfern
und knüppeln auf die demonstranten los
in hongkong sind am mittwoch tausende
menschen auf die straßen gegangen
sie verstießen damit gegen das
versammlungsverbot die polizei ging mit
wasserwerfern tränengas und pfefferspray
gegen die demonstranten vor
mehr als 300 menschen wurden
festgenommen die proteste richten sich
gegen das anfang der woche von der
chinesischen regierung verabschiedete
neue sicherheitsgesetze hongkong
es trat am 23 jahrestag der rückgabe der
ehemaligen britischen kronkolonie an
china in kraft das gesetz greift massiv
in die autonomierechte hongkongs ein die
bei dem souveränitäts wechsel 1997
gewährt worden waren
so sollen chinesische sicherheitsorgane
zukünftig eigenmächtig ermittlungen und
rechts hoheit ausüben können außerdem
soll unter anderem der besitz von
flaggen aufklebern und flugblätter die
unabhängigkeit hongkongs fordern
bestraft werden bei zuwiderhandlung
drohen eine lebenslange haft und eine
auslieferung an china auch für ausländer
internationale kritik an dem gesetz und
dem vorgehen gegen die demonstranten wie
china zurück und bei mir im studio ist
jetzt bald 14 paul ronzheimer porto war
es ja auch selbst schon vor ort was
macht das mit eventuell solche szenen
aus hongkong siehst es macht mich
traurig und erinnert mich an den letzten
winter als ich mehrere wochen von dort
berichtet habe wenn man wieder die
chance einen der anführer der proteste
dort getroffen habe der später auch in
deutschland berühmt wurde
als er auf einem foto bei einer bild
veranstaltung zusammen mit heiko maas zu
sehen war woraufhin die chinesische
regierung offiziell eingeschritten ist
dies kritisiert hat damals ist es zum
eklat gekommen
ja und josh young hat immer gewarnt in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten dass
china es ernst meint dass china als
ernst meint mit diesem sicherheitsgesetz
dieses sicherheitsgesetz das ihn und
alle anderen demonstranten und
aktivisten gefährdet weil theoretisch
ist es jetzt möglich für china für die
chinesischen polizisten dechant
festzunehmen die nach china zu bringen
und dort zu verurteilen und wie wir alle
wissen hat china nichts mit einem
rechtsstaat nichts mit demokratie zu tun
und deswegen sind die leute sind
menschen dort so wütend und was man
sagen muss ist wenn man dort auf den
straßen unterwegs ist und erlebt hat wie
hunderttausende teilweise millionen für
freiheit für demokratie auf die straße
gehen dann ist das auch aus einer
europäischen perspektive wahnsinnig
traurig mit anzusehen dass all das was
unsere politiker gesagt haben unter
anderem heiko maas aber auch kanzlerin
merkel überhaupt keinen einfluss haben
und sie sich vielleicht viel zu sehr
zurückgehalten haben sie haben selbst
daran festgehalten an einer konferenz an
einer eu china konferenz und wir sehen
das ergebnis
das ist gerade angesprochen die reaktion
aus deutscher sicht sind sehr
zurückhaltend was forderst du denn
welche konsequenzen sollte die
bundesregierung treffen ich denke
dadurch dass china jetzt dieses
sicherheitsgesetz umsetzt was ganz klar
alle freiheitsrechte die grundrechte und
die unabhängigkeit die für hongkong noch
weiter gegolten hat auch nach dem recht
nach der bestimmung die es damals
gegeben hat er müsste ist eigentlich
sanktionen geben gegen china das ist
meine meinung und das mindeste wäre
diese konferenz abzusagen und viel
klarere worte zu finden
die kanzlerin müsste sich viel heftiger
viel kritischer gegenüber dem äußern was
dort in china passiert aber wenn man
einmal mit der kanzlerin nach china
geflogen ist und das bin ich im letzten
herbst in der maschine der regierung
dann versteht man so ein bisschen warum
die kanzlerin das nicht will
denn die wirtschaftlichen interessen die
deutschland hat in china da gibt es alle
großen firmen dort werke haben vw
deutsche bank siemens aldi haben
natürlich die große angst und die große
furcht dass wenn in deutschland zu
kritisch ist wenn die kanzlerin zu
kritisch ist dass das arbeitsplätze
kostet und die kanzlerin muss man so
klar sagen ob sich der wirtschaft und
den wirtschaftlichen interessen dort
total unter danke schön paul ronzheimer
klare worte von dir und wir werden
natürlich da dran bleiben und auch
weiter berichten und weiterhin sehen